Traduttore: Eleonora Cavallo
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Il tempo.
Il tempo non esiste.
Ho 15 minuti per cercare
di convincervi di questo.
Prendete due orologi.
Possibilmente migliori di queste
due vecchie patacche di mio nonno.
Un po' più precisi, ok?
Assicuratevi che indichino la stessa ora.
Indicano la stessa ora,
la stessa di questa,
più o meno le 2:45.
Adesso provate ad alzarne
uno e abbassare l'altro
e tenerli così per un po' di tempo.
1, 2, 3.
Poi rimetterli insieme
e guardare cosa indicano.
Se gli orologi sono
un po' più precisi di questi,
non indicano più la stessa ora.
L'orologio messo più in alto è più avanti,
l'orologio messo più in basso
è più indietro.
Questo è un fatto.
Ovviamente
con degli orologi come questi
non è molto facile vederlo,
non sono abbastanza precisi,
ma oggi esistono orologi
estremamente precisi.
Questo è un esempio,
questo sta in Colorado,
è l'orologio atomico a Boulder.
È uno quelli che servono per fissare
il tempo ufficiale negli Stati Uniti.
Ne abbiamo di simili in Italia,
a Firenze, diversi,
ne esistono anche versioni
più piccole, commerciali
sufficienti per vedere questo effetto.
Sono delle scatolette.
Se voi ne prendete una
e la mettete in basso
e una la mettete in alto,
quando le mettete insieme
non segnano più lo stesso tempo.
Il tempo passa più rapidamente in alto
e più lentamente in basso.
È un fatto.
Per esempio, immaginate
di avere un fratello gemello,
avete la stessa età, crescete insieme.
Immaginate che vostro fratello
vada a vivere in montagna
e voi restate a vivere al mare.
Se vi incontrate dopo molto tempo,
vostro fratello è più vecchio
e voi siete più giovani.
Non sono solo gli orologi
che sono influenzati
dall'altezza del campo gravitazionale,
sono tutti i fenomeni
che avvengono nel tempo:
l'invecchiamento, la rapidità
a cui pensiamo, un fiore che sboccia.
Tutto.
Un pendolo che oscilla.
Il tempo passa più veloce in alto,
più lentamente in basso.
Pensate che quando
all'inizio degli anni '90
sono stati mandati in orbita
i primi satelliti per il GPS,
per i navigatori, queste cose
che abbiamo nelle nostre automobili
per dirci dove siamo, no?
I fisici hanno detto agli ingegneri:
"Attenzione perché lassù sui satelliti
il tempo passa più veloce".
Siccome per funzionare la macchinetta
sente il segnale di un satellite,
sui satelliti c'è un orologio.
L'orologio va più veloce
di quello che ci si aspetta quaggiù,
quindi bisognava tener conto di questo.
Gli ingegneri hanno detto: "Va bene".
L'intero progetto però era, ed è tuttora,
un progetto dell'esercito americano.
GPS gestito dall'esercito americano.
Quindi a capo del progetto
c'erano i generali americani.
I generali americani
sono generali dell'esercito,
quando gli hanno detto: "Là il tempo
va più lento, più veloce, ecc."
"Il tempo va più lento?
Più veloce? Non ci credo!"
Per cui i primi satelliti
sono stati mandati su
con un doppio sistema
che poteva funzionare tenendo conto
o non tenendo conto di questo effetto.
La versione che non teneva conto
di questo effetto,
non funzionava.
Il GPS non funzionerebbe
se non si tenesse conto
del fatto che là il tempo va più veloce.
E così anche i generali americani
si sono dovuti convincere
che effettivamente il tempo
va più veloce su.
Che vuol dire?
Vuole dire che il tempo
non è ciò che ci immaginiamo,
vuole dire che non possiamo
pensare a un unico tempo
che scorre uguale dappertutto.
In qualche modo, dobbiamo pensare
che in alto, in basso,
più a destra, più a sinistra,
per chi si muove più lento,
per chi si muove più veloce,
il tempo passa a velocità diverse.
Dobbiamo cambiare
la nostra immagine del mondo
da un unico orologio che batte il tempo,
a tanti orologi, ognuno che ha il suo.
Il mondo è un coro di tutti questi orologi
che vanno a velocità diverse.
Strano e difficile.
Se ci pensate non è la prima volta
che cambiamo la nostra immagine
del mondo, no?
La terra è piatta o la terra è rotonda?
Questa stanza è ferma
o si sta muovendo?
È ferma.
No, sappiamo che si sta muovendo,
gira intorno al Sole velocissima, no?
(Esitazione)
Una rondine viene da un'altra rondine,
sua mamma era una rondine,
sua nonna era una rondine,
e così via, rondine, rondine, rondine.
Io vengo da un essere umano
che è figlio di un altro essere umano
e di un altro essere umano.
È impossibile che io e una rondine
abbiamo gli stessi antenati comuni
E invece no.
Tutti abbiamo con le rondini
gli stessi antenati in comune.
Cos'è che succede in questi casi?
Succede che noi scopriamo
che abbiamo delle idee semplici,
naturali sul mondo che sono sbagliate.
Non perché siano
inadatte alla nostra vita.
Sono adatte alla nostra vita
ma proprio perché
sono adatte alla nostra vita,
sono buone alla nostra scala,
non sono più buone quando guardiamo
la vita non sulla scala
di 10, 100 o 1000 anni,
ma sulla scala di milioni di anni,
o quando pensiamo a cosa
succede molto lontano...
(Esitazione)
...con oggetti molto veloci,
molto piccoli, molto grandi.
C'è un esempio che a me
sta particolarmente a cuore,
e credo che sia utile per capire il tempo,
che è l'alto e il basso, no?
Le cose cascano dall'alto verso il basso.
Quello è l'alto.
Questo è il basso.
È una delle strutture fondamentali
del mondo come lo immaginiamo.
Noi organizziamo il mondo
in termini di alto e basso, no?
Quindi nell'universo
ci sono l'alto e il basso, ok?
Una direzione universale
che è l'alto e una che è il basso.
Non è proprio vero, no?
Quello che è alto qui, è basso a Sydney.
Non solo, ma se noi usciamo dalla Terra
non c'è proprio l'alto e il basso.
Gli astronauti, abbiamo visto
nelle immagini,
si muovono da tutte le parti.
La nozione di alto e basso
non c'è nell'universo.
È una nozione
che vale solo qui per noi.
È comoda e utile per organizzare
i fenomeni intorno a noi,
ma diventa inutile e insensata
appena usciamo dal nostro pianeta
e andiamo da qui alla Luna,
come hanno fatto i nostri astronauti.
In tutti questi casi
scopriamo che la nostra immagine
semplice del mondo è sbagliata
e le cose sono un po' più complesse.
La cosa bella
è che in tutti questi casi, compreso
il tempo, adesso ci ritorno al tempo...
(Esitazione)
Adesso è facile pensare
che la Terra è rotonda,
che fuori dalla Terra non ci sono
l'alto e il basso, no?
Abbiamo visto le foto fatte
dagli astronauti dell'Apollo 11
andando verso la Luna.
La Terra è rotonda.
Ma l'abbiamo capito prima.
Qualcuno l'ha capito prima
che la Terra è rotonda, no?
Aristotele lo sapeva,
Anassimandro l'aveva capito
che la Terra è una palla che vola.
La Terra si muove.
Adesso l'abbiamo vista
muoversi da fuori,
ma Galileo e Copernico l'avevano capito
prima, senza bisogno di vederla.
Darwin non ha visto
le specie che cambiano,
l'ha capito.
Come hanno fatto
queste persone a capirlo?
Semplicemente partendo
da quello che si sa del mondo,
osservando, mettendo insieme i fatti noti
e accorgendosi che i fatti noti
sono comprensibili meglio
se cambiamo qualche cosa
nella nostra struttura,
nella nostra immagine del mondo.
In questa maniera, tutte queste persone
sono arrivate a capire qualcosa di nuovo,
di cruciale.
Questo fatto
che il tempo va più lento più in basso
e più veloce più in alto,
che oggi si osserva, basta comprarsi
questi orologi molto precisi
e chiunque di noi può osservarlo.
È stato compreso prima
che fosse osservato, da Einstein.
100 anni fa quasi, 97 anni fa nel 1915,
semplicemente cercando
di chiarirsi le idee
sulla fisica del mondo conosciuta
al suo tempo.
Einstein aveva da un lato la teoria
di Newton, le grandi teorie meccaniche,
dall'altro l'elettromagnetismo.
Sforzandosi di trovare il modo
di combinare queste due cose,
di avere un'immagine del mondo coerente,
ha capito che il tempo non è una cosa
che passa uguale per tutti,
ma che ci sono tanti tempi.
Il tempo passa a velocità diverse.
Questo 100 anni fa.
Oggi sta succedendo la stessa cosa,
perché oggi siamo di nuovo
nella stessa situazione.
Oggi abbiamo da un alto ereditato
le bellissime teorie di Einstein,
che nel frattempo abbiamo scoperto
che funzionano benissimo,
le abbiamo confermate,
abbiamo visto che ci sono i buchi neri.
Dall'altro lato lungo tutto il XX secolo
è cresciuta la meccanica quantistica.
Questa mattina abbiamo sentito
Marco raccontarci del mondo
della fisica delle particelle,
tutto fatto con la meccanica quantistica,
una bella teoria del moto,
che però non combacia bene
con le teorie di Einstein
e con la relatività generale.
E allora la scienza cerca di rifare
ancora una volta questo tentativo
di usare quello che sappiamo
per cercare di guardare più in là.
Nel 1963 due grandissimi
scienziati americani
Joe Wheeler, il signore nella foto
in bianco e nero,
e Bryce DeWitt, il signore
nella foto a colori,
hanno semplicemente preso l'equazione
della relatività generale di Einstein
e la meccanica quantistica,
le hanno messe insieme
e hanno scritto un'equazione,
che Wheeler chiamava
"l'equazione di DeWitt"
e DeWitt "l'equazione di Wheeler",
e il resto del mondo un po' stufo
chiamava "equazione Wheeler-DeWitt".
È questa qua, no?
Di cui non vi racconto i dettagli.
Un'equazione che all'inizio
era molto confusa.
È stata molto studiata
e oggi continuiamo a studiarla.
Oggi la teoria è evoluta, riusciamo
a scriverla in maniera precisa,
e riusciamo a capire meglio
quello che significa.
Questo è il mio lavoro.
Questa equazione ha una caratteristica
che allora fu stupefacente,
e lasciò tutti a bocca aperta.
Questa equazione è nata mettendo insieme
quello che sappiamo sul mondo
da una parte e dall'altra.
Ha la caratteristica seguente:
tutte le equazioni, se vi ricordate
qualcosa della fisica della scuola,
tutte le equazioni importanti,
fondamentali della fisica
da Galileo a Newton,
Maxwell, Einstein, ecc.
ci dicono come cambiano le cose nel tempo,
torniamo al tempo.
E quindi hanno tutte "t" dentro,
il tempo o la velocità, l'accelerazione,
cambiamenti nel tempo,
c'è sempre il tempo nell'equazione.
Questa equazione qui
non ha il tempo dentro,
la variabile tempo è saltata via,
scompare, non c'è.
È come se cercando di scrivere
tutto quello che sappiamo del mondo
non ci fosse più il tempo.
Che significa?
Questo è quello che cerco di spiegarvi
nei rimanenti 4 minuti.
Se mi ascoltate con attenzione,
spero di riuscire a chiarirvi
cosa significa scrivere un'equazione
del mondo senza il tempo.
Torniamo alla fisica più semplice,
la prima cosa che studiano i ragazzi
che si iscrivono a Fisica
è come si muove un pendolo ad esempio,
qualunque cosa che si muova.
Dobbiamo descrivere come cambia
la posizione nel tempo.
Quindi dobbiamo misurare la posizione
e il tempo con l'orologio, ok?
Guardiamo dov'è la posizione
e guardiamo dov'è l'orologio,
facciamo la tabella
e scriviamo un'equazione
che descriva come cambia questa posizione
nel tempo.
Ma qui non guardiamo il tempo,
qui guardiamo la posizione
della lancetta, no?
La lancetta si muove
e questo si muove.
Noi stiamo descrivendo
come cambia questa posizione
quando la posizione della lancetta cambia.
Se ci pensate facciamo sempre così.
Noi descriviamo sempre qualcosa
in funzione di qualcos'altro.
Gli orologi non sono che delle cose
come delle altre che si muovono
che hanno la caratteristica
di muoversi tutti insieme,
più o meno tutti insieme.
Questo cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che noi potremmo
fare a meno del tempo
e parlare solo di come si muove
il pendolo in funzione della lancetta.
Io potrei dire invece di:
mi sono svegliato alle 8 stamattina,
mi sono svegliato nel momento
in cui il sole stava là.
Ho cominciato a parlare nel momento
in cui si sono spente le luci, ecc.
Senza mai fare riferimento al tempo.
Per esempio alto e basso.
Io posso dire questo sta in alto
e questo sta in basso,
ma posso fare a meno di dire alto e basso.
Posso dire questo
sta verso quella luce forte là
e questo sta verso il tondo rosso
sotto di me.
Se io sono sulla Terra mi complico la vita
ma se io sono un astronauta
dentro una capsula
e dico al mio amico: "Ehi Anderson,
passami l'orologio quello in alto".
E lui mi dice: "Quale in alto?"
(Risate)
Se invece gli dico: "Quello verso il
tappeto rosso".
Lui: "Ah, quello verso il tappeto rosso".
Quindi la nozione di alto e basso
perde di utilità appena esco dalla Terra.
Bene, la nozione di tempo
perde di utilità, sparisce
appena esco da un ambito normale
ed entro nell'ambito
in cui sono obbligato
a usare la gravità quantistica,
questa equazione qui.
E cos'è questo ambito?
Le cose estremamente grandi
o estremamente piccole.
Là dove ancora non abbiamo
le idee chiare sul mondo.
Se noi guardiamo nell'estremamente piccolo
la scala estremamente piccola,
lo spazio stesso fluttua, salta,
è fatto come un mare in tempesta,
anzi è lo spaziotempo addirittura
nell'estremamente piccolo,
come se il tempo saltasse.
Questi orologi, che ognuno tesse
un suo cammino a una velocità diversa,
in ambito piccolissimo vanno avanti
e indietro, si muovono, ecc. ecc.
In questa scala estremamente piccola
non funziona più bene la nozione di tempo.
E quindi noi dobbiamo ridescrivere
il mondo nei termini delle variabili.
Una per una, senza fare
riferimento al tempo.
Come se avessimo tanti orologi
che hanno perso le lancette
e possiamo dire solo come
si muovono una rispetto all'altra.
Immaginate, per dare un'idea,
che noi pensiamo al mondo come
un insieme di cose che si muovono
che cambiano, che danzano tutte insieme,
con il tempo che è il direttore
d'orchestra che dà il ritmo.
1, 2, 1, 2...tutti insieme...1, 2,
Questa immagine non funziona
più nel piccolo,
nel piccolissimo non c'è più
un unico ritmo di tutti
e il modo è come se fosse una danza
di ogni micropezzo
del mondo con il vicino
e non tutti insieme.
Qual è la morale di tutta questa storia?
Il tempo è un concetto utile,
che organizza
la nostra esperienza quotidiana
ma non è un concetto fondamentale.
Così come l'alto e il basso
sono concetti molto utili
ma non servono più appena usciamo
dall'ambito della nostra quotidianità.
Questo vale per un sacco di cose.
Quello che a me piace
della scienza è questo.
Quello che ci insegna la scienza
è che la nostra immagine del mondo,
la nostra percezione del mondo,
molto spesso è sbagliata, è limitata,
vale solo nel nostro ambito.
E l'umanità intera è come qualcuno
nato nel suo paesello
dove tutti fanno la stessa cosa
poi esce e dice: "Ah, ma c'è altro.
Si possono mangiare le altre cose,
si possono dire le altre cose,
si parlano le altre lingue,
si hanno delle altre idee".
L'umanità intera esce
dalla piccolezza dei suoi pensieri
e scopre che tutto è diverso:
le specie si trasformano l'una nell'altra,
l'alto e il basso non sono veri,
il tempo non è quella cosa lì.
Il mondo intero è più grande, più bello,
più variegato e più divertente
di quello che ci sembra a prima vista.
Questa cosa un po' banale
fatta di alto e basso,
con persone che si muovono
e sassi che cadono.
È più ricco.
E per comprenderlo
il sapere antico serve poco.
Tutto il sapere antico,
quello che ci insegnano i nostri padri
in fondo vale solo qui.
Appena guardiamo
un po' più in là non vale più.
Come hanno detto nel primo video
di oggi, l'universo è sterminato
noi nasciamo in un angolino piccolissimo,
abbiamo idee che valgono
per questo angolino piccolissimo,
quando cominciamo a guardare più in là.
Io credo che quello che scopriamo
a ogni passo,
questa è la conclusione,
è molto più sterminato, più bello,
più complesso di qualunque delle idee
che ci raccontano i nostri padri
o che abbiamo imparato da mamma e papà.
Questa bellezza che ci travolge,
questo mistero
che c'è sempre davanti a noi
a cui accediamo passo a passo,
poco a poco,
ma che resta sempre sconfinato,
ci attira, ci affascina
e vogliamo andare a vederlo.
Per me questa è la scienza.
Grazie.
(Applausi)